siempre el primer paso es observar la
estructura del alumno de alquilo y si
tenemos un alumno de alquilo secundario
entonces puede ser cualquiera de estas
cuatro posibilidades puede ser sn 1 s n
2 y 1 o 2
una vez que identificaron la estructura
del alumno de alquilo enfóquense en el
núcleo filo en este caso el núcleo filo
s lannion hidrosur foro clasificamos al
núcleo filo como fuerte o débil sabemos
que es un ejemplo del núcleo filo fuerte
lo que nos lleva a pensar que puede ser
una reacción por la vía sn 2 ya que las
reacciones por el mecanismo sn dos
necesitan núcleo filos fuertes
el litro sulfuro es una base fuerte o
débil bueno es una base débil porque es
un ácido conjugado fuerte y finalmente
veamos al solvente sabemos que el de m&s
o es un solvente polar apro tico polar
apro tico
y eso favorece las reacciones sn dos así
que ya tenemos dos pistas que nos
indican que probablemente sea la
reacción sn dos dibujemos el producto
que resultaría por la vía sn dos aquí
tenemos un centro girar el avión hidro
sulfuro atacará a este carbono del lado
opuesto a donde se encuentra el bromo
así cuando el bromo sale se añade el sh
y se da la inversión de la configuración
este es el producto que se obtiene con
el mecanismo sn 2
veamos otro pondré el mismo reactivo
este es nuestro centro kieran esta
molécula ahora reaccionará con ácido
fórmico
así nos queda el ácido fórmico
y calentaremos ligeramente
ok una vez más clasificamos al núcleo
filo este par de electrones en el
oxígeno no le dan una carga formal
negativa entonces es un núcleo filo
débil y eso nos lleva a la posibilidad
de una reacción sn 1
ahora cuando pensamos en el ácido
fórmico como una base bueno es un ácido
así que no es una base muy fuerte el
ácido fórmico es una base débil y ahora
el solvente en este caso el núcleo filo
también actúa como el solvente los
ácidos carboxílicos se clasifican como
solventes polares prácticos el solvente
es polar pro tico y esto también nos
lleva a la reacción sn 1 porque un
solvente polar pro tico estabiliza al
kart vocación que se formará un carbó
catión seco
dario si tomamos en cuenta la stereo
química de esto cuando ataca la porción
núcleo física de esta molécula podemos
obtener la retención de la configuración
perdemos un protón en este mecanismo
pero no lo dibujaré para ahorrar tiempo
también obtenemos la inversión de la
configuración estos son dos posibles
productos que además resultan ser
enantiómero si el mecanismo ocurre por
la vía sn uno muy bien dibujemos el
mismo reactivo otra vez aquí está
nuestro centro quiral y el bromo está
justo aquí esta vez haremos reaccionar a
esta molécula con el óxido de sodio y
nuestro solvente es el etanol veamos qué
sucede ahora sabemos que es una luro de
alquilo secundario ahora clasificamos al
núcleo filo el año net óxido como es un
alcohol
se considera un núcleo filo fuerte y eso
me lleva a la posibilidad del mecanismo
sn 2 ahora en términos de basic y that
el stock sido de sodio es una base
fuerte quiere un protón fuerte y algo
fuerte me lleva a pensar en eliminación
así que un mecanismo es dos puede
ocurrir cuando se tiene una base fuerte
y luego el solvente que es el etanol es
un solvente polar práctico polar
práctico y eso tendrá un efecto mayor en
los productos porque un solvente polar
práctico sol matará al núcleo filo
dibujaré cómo sería el núcleo filoso
atado el núcleo filo es el año net óxido
tiene una carga formal negativa y cuando
el solvente aparece
y esta el etanol dibujaré otra molécula
de etanol
el oxígeno tiene una carga parcial
negativa y el hidrógeno una carga
parcial positiva como los hidrógenos son
parcialmente positivos pueden
interactuar con el oxígeno que está
cargado negativamente hay una
interacción imaginen un montón de
moléculas alrededor del núcleo filo al
sol but are el núcleo filo disminuyen su
fuerza porque la carga formal negativa
se balancea con todas estas cargas
parciales positivas
eso significa que disminuye la
probabilidad de la reacción por la vía
del mecanismo sn 2 y se favorece la de 2
si observamos el allure o de alc y lo
que tenemos originalmente este es
nuestro carbono alfa y estos son los
carbonos beta
este es el carbono beta 1 y este es el
carbono beta 2
la reacción ocurre cuando la base toma
protón ya sea del carbono beta 1 o del
beta 2 digamos que lo toma del beta 1
formaremos un al que no podemos formar
al producto trans el doble enlace se
forme entre el carbono alfa y beta y
también se forma el producto si sabemos
que el producto mayor es el trans porque
es más estable que el cis menor
por la vía del mecanismo éstos obtenemos
dos productos con el carbono beta 1 pero
aún podemos obtener otro producto con el
carbono beta 2 se forma un doble enlace
entre este carbono beta y nuestro
carbono alfa nos queda este producto que
también es posible pero el mayor será el
producto trans luego es el producto 6 y
después sería este producto un al que no
mono sustituido y recuerden que los y
sustituidos como estos dos son más
estables y aunque dijimos que la
probabilidad de la reacción sn 2 era
menor se logra obtener un producto por
esa vía el año net óxido al ser un
núcleo filo fuerte ataca al centro
quiral y nos queda un producto como éste
como ataca del lado contrario a donde se
encontraba el bromo el oxígeno con el
grupo de tilo nos queda lejos de
nosotros
este también es un producto que se
obtiene en menor cantidad pero si
quisieran obtenerlo en mayor cantidad
sólo tendrían que cambiar el solvente si
lo cambiáramos de polar práctico a polar
a práctico como por ejemplo de m&s o eso
aumentará la fuerza núcleo física de led
a óxido y también la cantidad de los
productos obtenidos por la vía sn 2 ya
vimos s n 1 y 2 y s n 2 la vía y 1
también es posible aunque no es muy
común en un alumno de alquilo puede
ocurrir pero no es práctico en realidad
se puede ver mejor en un alcohol
secundario como por ejemplo esta
molécula
aquí tenemos al ciclohexano y lo haremos
reaccionar con h2so4 ácido sulfúrico es
un ácido fuerte
no podemos clasificarlo como un núcleo
filo pero sólo quiero que reconozcan el
mecanismo el ácido sulfúrico dona
protones que están flotando en la
solución y un par de electrones del
oxígeno recoge uno de estos protones
será un buen grupo saliente el h no es
un buen grupo saliente pero ya protón
hado es excelente
ahí está aquí hay una carga formal
positiva así que estos electrones se
irán junto con el oxígeno se forma un
kart vocación un kart vocación nos dice
que será una eliminación 1 cuando la
molécula de agua sale la base ya sea
agua misma o una base con jugada del
ácido sulfúrico
en un protón y finalmente obtenemos a
nuestro alterno
este fue un mecanismo por la vía 1 y nos
quedó el ciclo externo así que vimos s n
2 s n 1 2 y 1 con los saludos de alc y
los secundarios es un poco más
complicado pero la clave está en
analizar cada uno de los componentes de
la reacción y averiguar cuál es el mejor
mecanismo con base en la fuerza núcleo
física será fuerte o será débil también
tomen en cuenta al solvente y no olviden
siempre empezar primero por la
estructura del allure o de al kilo